here with more on China as well as
America's behind-the-scenes effort to
get thousands of Americans back home
during this outbreak as Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo mr. secretary I I know
for a fact that you have gotten people
we had people on missions you've gotten
them home safely people all across the
globe you've been working 24/7 I want
people to know what you've been doing
behind the scenes well Sean thanks
thanks for having me on the show tonight
the State Department teams done amazing
work over 25,000 Americans returned home
when airports all across the world roads
across the world were closed what health
care facilities across the world were
closed
these Americans wanted to come home
25,000 Americans 50 countries some
dozens and dozens of flights we've got
several thousand more people to get home
and the State Department is hard at work
if you heard some of these stories you
just heard the story of the Comfort the
story from Samaritan's Purse if you
heard the stories of what the State
Department's done to get people out of
places like Bhutan and possible place to
get to we had a sick American an
American citizen who was suffering we
got him out we got him back we got him
to safety a truly good work to bring
Americans hope it's the best of what the
Trump administration has demonstrated in
this enormous crisis yep mr. secretary
we gotta deal with this issue in China
do you are you confident now they have
valuable Intel and information that
could help the world after they hid this
when you said the last time on the show
you would have gladly sent our experts
over to help them yeah Shawn president
Trump and I have been committed to
making sure that we had the best date
available when you hear doctors pouchy
and Burks talk about risk talk about
fatalities trying to think about how to
model what they need is data they need
data from Italy they need data from
China they need data from Iran we need
every country to step up and provide
accurate transparent information if we
can't have that if we have
disinformation instead there are more
lives that will be at risk not only
today but in the weeks ahead as we
battle this enormous challenge we've
asked every country to step up tell us
what they know so that the world can
learn America will then turn around we
will share
information we get and will keep people
safe not only here in the United States
but all across the world you're having a
problem with I read the last time on
this program you actually said if they
ask for help you would give it tell us
what's going on we have repeatedly
offered the people of Iran assistance we
will this is a humanitarian crisis
inside the Islamic Republic of Iran as
well we've offered to provide
humanitarian assistance we've offered to
provide assistance they don't want to
take it from America to help other
countries get their assistance into the
country that offers stood then that
offer stands now sadly the Islamic
Republic Iran's regime the leadership
has rejected those offers if
humanitarian assistance from us here in
America it's really unfortunate for the
Iranian people that when the Iranians
die
a lot of it has been made over calling
it the Wuhan virus and you took issue
with anybody saying sorry we do that
with a lot of other illnesses yeah
president Trump was very clear I think
he even said it again this morning is he
talked about as being the the Chinese
coronavirus what we've been looking for
here all along is we simply want to make
sure we understand what's happened so
that we can prevent the loss of life
moving forward we're looking to
cooperate with every country we'd love
to cooperate with the Chinese as well to
get the right information so that we can
do all that's needed to find
therapeutics to find a vaccine to do
everything we can to reduce the risk
that there will be more lives lost as
the world moves forward mr. secretary
thank you thank you for bringing home
all of those Americans that story will
be told